In this video we shall review how to track issues over time.
PURPS for Enterprise Edition generates stats and charts to help you track your progress
over time.
The trend analysis features make sure you always have access to information about your
security posture and can quickly identify areas for improvement.
Once you've completed a few scans, the dashboard for the site displays several charts that
show you how your security issues have changed over time.
These include changes by issue type, changes by severity, security posture, new and resolved
issues.
A new issue is an issue that was discovered by a scan that were either not seen before
anywhere on the site or seen before but at a different URL.
Regressed issues are issues that were found in a previous scan, were resolved but have
now reappeared in the most recent scan.
A resolved issue is an issue that was found in a previous scan but was no longer found
by the most recent scan.
Additionally, you can view your trends by folder.
If you select the folder that contains a number of sites, this will aggregate all of the data
together for the sites contained within the folder.
You might find this useful for tracking a team's progress for example.
Thank you.